Kamilo beach is one of the dirtiest beaches in the world.
A lot of the currents bring plastic in from the open ocean.
The name Kamilo actually translates to "twisting currents".
I went there to do a little bit of a beach cleanup and scope the area out.
And that's when I started interacting with the material and seeing how I could use it,...
...which inspired me to take action and to start Nurdle in the Rough.
Nurdle in the Rough jewelry is jewelry that's made from ocean plastic.
A lot of times people come up to me and ask me what kind of stone I'm wearing.
It's really a great segue into a conversation about how much plastic is in our oceans.
I'm really passionate about taking this ugly plastic pollution...
...and transforming it into something beautiful...
...these gemstones that are sleek and they have these beautiful textures...
...and lines on them that tell the story of where this plastic has been.
I cut the material up and I start rounding and shaping it and polishing it down by hand.
I use all recycled sterling silver and I set the marine debris like I would a stone.
I try to make designs that are eye-catching and have a little bit of an intrigue.
Some are inspired by sea life...
...and some are inspired by the beauty that I find in the material.